so I want to talk about some more
attributes of this structure okay
now broadly speaking what we're going to
say is that a motivation sets up one of
these frameworks I'm going to call this
framework a story now there's a lots of
things you could call it you could call
it an expectancy model you could call it
a game I'm going to call it a story and
we're going to say well what you do is
you you have a life story and your life
story is composed of nested sub stories
you could also think of it as a
personality but a story is like a
personality in action so we'll just
stick with story the story has a
starting place that's where you are and
the story has an endpoint that's where
you're going and you're always in one of
those stories or you're asleep so you're
either pursuing something in the real
world that is a value or you're like
that's directly motivated or you're
pursuing another situation where the
reason you're pursuing it is because it
fulfills a bunch of motivational states
now and into the future so that's what
you're doing say when you pursue a
career and if you're not doing that then
your mind is wandering and what it's
doing is it's wandering through the
space of hypothetical worlds where you
could play hypothetic hypothetical roles
and if you're not doing that then you're
asleep so you're in one of these all the
time
now they shift and that's one of the
things that's quite interesting about
them the shift can take place on all
sorts of levels you can differently
conceptualize the way where you are you
can differently conceptualize where
you're going and you can differently
conceptualize how you're going to get
there now I won't go into that for the
moment
so let's say you're going from point A
to point B and at the highest level of
resolution that means that you're acting
and then other things that happen is not
only are you acting you're configuring
your perceptions we already talked a
little bit about this you know what you
should highlight what you should bring
your high resolution thinking to bear on
and you know what you should ignore and
what you should ignore is those things
that are likely to remain constant as
you pursue this set of transformations
and/or that aren't going to interfere
with what you're doing and so you just
have to concentrate especially if you
set your environment up properly and
that's another thing part of the way
that people deal with the complexity of
the world is by just not having it
around you know so for example even if
you look in this room a lot of things
are radically simplified so that you
don't get overwhelmed how many of you
have computers here okay now what does
your computer look like keyboard screen
what about the rest of it flat shiny
aluminum why because you want to act
like that's one thing you don't want to
act like it's how many transistors are
on a chip now like a billion or more a
lot like they're down to molecular size
those things say they're so small now
this is really funny they're so small
now that
so imagine electrons running along the
wire now the weird thing about an
electron is it might be there it might
be somewhere else so it's got this vague
nonlocality about it you know like maybe
it's supposed to be there but it's
actually over there that would happen
now and then but the wires are so damn
thin now that there's some good
probability that the electron will be
outside the wire and that causes short
circuits so that's quite also you've got
quantum level complexity mucking up your
your circuitry in your computer but look
look the computer is designed this way
right it's designed so you can ignore it
the outside of it's a flat shell it's
it's a low resolution image and not the
keyboard because you have to move it not
the screen but everything else is like
flat the designer the primate designer
of this computer does not want your poor
primate brain to be overwhelmed by
the fact that this thing is
incomprehensibly complex cars are the
same they have that nice shiny shell on
them and so that you can just sort of
low-resolution it and that's good enough
the walls painted roughly the same color
like we're doing a lot of things around
us to to reduce the sensory load plus
there are people dealing away at the
background like mad making sure the
lights stay on making sure the heat
stays on you know making sure that you
have air in here the place isn't burning
down there aren't crazy people wandering
around here with shotguns and rifles and
like there's a lot going on so that you
can sit here and pretend that you know
enough to stay alive so we're we're also
removing a tremendous amount of
complexity as a consequence of social
cooperation okay so so these are all
parts of the way that you simplify the
world you're in a radical simplification
structure that's the external society
then within that there's only certain
things you want and then within that
there's only certain things you can
detect and then with it in that there's
only certain features that pop out as
necessary to contemplate in the realm
that you're dealing with now one thing
you might ask is well what time span are
usually dealing with you know because
what the world's made of depends on the
time span and that's a tough one we know
that it's more than one tenth of a
second but you can think years into the
future right so I might say well why are
you going to university or I might say
what are you doing right now and then
the answer would be well I'm sitting in
class and then the question would be
well why are you sitting in class and
the answer that would be well because I
I want to take this course and why well
it's because I want to get my degree so
why well because I want to be prepared
for a career and a you know a productive
and high-quality life when I get out
well why well you know you can keep
saying why pretty much indefinitely and
as you answer you go farther and farther
out in time scales now it's a tricky
thing because one of the things I might
tell you this is a very complex
cognitive problem is well where should
you stop so for example um I could say
to you do you want $100 now or do you
want 50
thousand years in 75 years you're gonna
think well I'll probably take the
hundred dollars now well how about two
hundred years it's like well I'm not
going to be there I'll take 100 bucks
now what's obviously thinking out 200
years is not that helpful now you might
think well no you should calculate the
effects of your actions on the fastest
time span possible and include the
largest number of people if you're
really going to elaborate it but the
problem is you can't do the computations
because you get you get this thing
called combinatorial explosion happening
which is that it's like a chessboard you
make one move okay fine
but then you could make four and then
with each of those you could make four
more and then with each of those you
could make four more and soon if you're
looking twenty moves ahead it's like
there's so many moves that the other
person could possibly make that looking
that far ahead is pointless
you can't do the computations and so we
don't know how far you should look into
the future it depends on how stable your
environment is but one month seems ok a
year yeah three to five years that's
what I'll have you do when you do the
future authoring program 20 years hmm
probably not and the reason for that is
the margin of error in your prediction
grow so large that your prediction is
worth anything and you can really see
how that's the case now just like what's
going to be like in 20 years when I was
a kid I used to read science fiction
it's like plausible accounts of the
potential future it's like now who knows
anything could happen
anything could happen you know you could
be 3/4 robot in 20 years you could have
a lifespan of 10,000 years I mean we
just do not know we could be living in
caves again with everything in runes we
don't have a clue what's going to help
so 20 years span I would say you know
get friendly with computers so 20 years
spans too long so ok anyways what what
I'm pointing out is that you have to
calculate you have to calculate what
you're doing across multiple spans of
time and in that combination you know in
combination with many many people and
that makes things very complex but
that's how that's how you're building
the structures that you live with it all
right so back to this
you're at point a you're going to point
B so you are somewhere now that's
interesting you are somewhat now
generally what people think about when
they think about being somewhere is that
they're in a place but you're not just
in a place you're in a place at a time
and I really want to stress that because
we know that the universe we know that
the environment is four-dimensional not
three dimension and that's important
because you can you can be in the same
place and in the next second you're
still where you were but you're in a
completely different place so for
example if someone walked in here with a
with a pistol this would not be the same
place okay so there's reason I'm telling
you that and then there's the future and
that's also a place and time and a place
in space okay now you're getting from
one point to the other and you're going
to do that by implementing certain
behaviors now you might say what can
happen while you're doing that well
here's three things that can happen the
thing you want that can happen something
you don't want but that you understand
and something you don't understand at
all something completley beyond your
comprehension and that would generally
be a traumatizing event of some force so
you can either know what's going to
happen or you can not know but still be
able to cope with it or you can not know
and not cope with it and of the negative
ones they correspond to that hierarchy
right if it's a little thing that you
don't understand you just modify a
little behavior if it's a big thing that
you don't understand well then what well
then everything falls apart you don't
know where you are don't know where
you're going and all the behaviors you
have are not helpful
and that's when your world falls apart
okay so generally that doesn't happen so
you I want to walk to the let's say I
set my target on the door I'm going to
walk to the door so here's what happens
instantly I'm slightly I have slight
negative motion about the fact that any
of you people in the way exist because
what my brain is doing is reconfiguring
the world to chart a straight path and
anything that's
in the way is going to make me uneasy
frustrated disappointed anxious and you
can think about this when you do house
design by the way so when you're setting
up a room what you want to do is figure
out what the room is for then you want
to clear the paths for that because then
when you walk into the room the room
will say welcome you can do the things
you want to do here easily and if you
don't do that it's all cluttered up it's
like there's no difference between that
and being confused mentally it's exactly
the same thing so okay so let's say now
I stand up and that works and then I
walk that way in that way in that way I
keep my eyes on the door and I'm getting
towards the door well I'm Maude modest
moderately positive about that because
I'm getting where I'm going but I'm also
moderately positive about it because it
the fact that I'm getting where I'm
going validates my whole theory so one
of the things that the behaviors didn't
get right when they were thinking about
punishment like if an animal lays out a
behavior you punish it will start
manifesting that behavior but but that
isn't all that happens you think about
punishing a human being
they stop manifesting the behavior but
the behavior isn't the whole damn thing
the thing they're in is this it's the
whole thing it's a conception of where
they are it's a conception of where
they're going and it's all the behaviors
that they might need to get there so you
know maybe those try to circumvent the
punishment walk around it maybe they'll
try a few more behaviors but what
happens you know
so I'm tied by a chain and I don't know
what I'm tied by a chain to the wall I
start walking that way and I figure out
that I'm chained well so much for that
stupid theory I'm not getting to the
door I'm going to let that view of the
world disintegrate I'm going to be very
upset about that and then I have to come
up with another one which might be well
how do I get rid of the chain so when
you fail two things happen the behavior
that you're manifesting doesn't work
that's the whole behaviorist routine but
it's worse than that because the whole
little personality that you're using to
construe the world falls apart and the
more
important the thing is that has fallen
apart the more of a catastrophe it's
going to be for you okay so let's say
you're going to medical school that's
what you want to do alright so you're
taking the course to write the exam to
pass the course with an A to apply to
medical school to get into medical
school to become a doctor you've failed
the test
what just happened well did your whole
future fall apart or did you just fail
the test well who knows right maybe your
whole future just fell apart it's like
now you have a GPA of 3.3 it's like nope
you have to go to you have to go to the
Caribbean to a private medical school
you're not going to get in anywhere in
Canada or the United States it's like
okay is your life over you jump off a
bridge well sometimes people do and it's
because the little sub personality that
they created which is the me that will
be a doctor it's one of these things
little story it's so integral to their
entire identity that when it collapses
they're done and people get suicidal
when that sort of thing happens okay so
well what are you supposed to do when
that happens well that's something that
we'll talk about you know from the
perspective of Mental Hygiene one of the
things I would recommend is that when
things go wrong for you you start at the
highest level of resolution in your
hierarchy and work upward you don't say
well god now everything's over you know
you might say okay what can I do to
ensure that I do better on the next test
so then you could I you could analyze
your subroutines your micro subroutines
like how much do you study a day well
sometimes people will tell me I study
six hours a day it's like no you don't
you sit in front of what you're supposed
to be doing for six hours a day but if
you actually study for more than three I
would be shocked because I've met almost
no one in my entire life who can sustain
high level concentration for more than
three hours for more than six days a
week for more than a year you'll just
burn yourself to a crisp so no you're
deluding yourself into thinking that
you're studying for six hours a day
you'd be way better off to cut it down
to two and a half and actually do it
like there's micro routine analysis that
you can do so that might be helpful then
you can implement that and run it that's
what you do if you're a behavioral
psychologist
someone comes and says my life's over
and you say well let's go for the micro
routines what do you mean well they say
well I can't be a doctor well okay
could you be a nurse would that work
could you be like a medical technician
you know could you be what else could
you be could you be a social worker etc
like okay so you're your domain is
helpful medical type of person well one
element of that is doctor but it doesn't
exhaust the entire realm of
possibilities so I'd say like flex up a
bit you know it's not the only path and
so that would be a more high level
adjustment that'd be more cognitive
adjustment if you were in cognitive
behavioral therapy it's like let's check
out your subroutines make you more
effective at studying but you know let's
loosen up your top level abstractions
you should be a good person let's say
whatever you decide that means one
element of that is be productively
employed in a way that doesn't make you
bitter and nasty okay doctor might be
one way of solving that although I
wouldn't be so sure about that
but it's not the only way of solving it
so all right you go from point A to B
you go from point A to point B and
things can happen along the way things
you like positive emotion you're getting
there plus you write things that produce
negative emotion you're not getting
there okay you can either solve them
easily small behavioral adjustment or
you have to go up the hierarchy of value
and adjust it with the least possible
damage generally speaking because that's
another rule of thumb in therapy it's
like I can't be a doctor so I'm going to
be a an engineer it's like well no
you've got three years behind you don't
just throw it away you know use what
you've already got make a minor course
deviation if you can do it have you know
maybe we could talk about broader scale
transformations but they're costly you
know stick as close to the path as you
can while altering it enough so that you
proceed on to your final goal and so
and that leads us and I think this is
where we'll stop today that leads us to
the next part of the story so here's the
kind of story that someone can tell I
was at point a and I went to point B and
here's how I did it and you're pretty
happy about that story maybe you go on
the YouTube and I found this year ago I
had this old car and I want to put a
stereo in it and so I typed in how to
put a stereo in Ex old car and there's
some helpful retired southern guy who
you know made a YouTube video to it so
and I was interested in his little story
because I he put a car stereo he didn't
have a car stereo in his car and he
wanted one and I didn't have a car
steering my care and I wanted one so his
little story about how to do that was
very interesting to me so I ran that
little tape and I did it's like great
not particularly transformation but good
enough good enough got some information
all right so that's an alright story and
you're running around all the time
interfacing with other people and you're
telling them your little story and
they're telling you their little story
but you know so that's one thing that
interests people how to do something
successfully but a lot of what people
talk about is something different which
is I was trying to get from point A to B
and it didn't work and now I'm at a
place where it didn't work and so it's a
problem right it's like the world's
opened up around me I don't know what to
do and the reason you talk to people
about that is because they have brains
and so do you and you might as well have
two brains working on the problem if you
can and if you're reciprocal you know
you're in trouble you come to me and we
talk it out maybe I can help and then
because we're playing a iterative game
now you owe me a favor
now you know I'm not going to be too
restrictive about that but you know
socially intelligent people are
reciprocal and Ben Franklin once said
you're doing a neighborhood what what
what should you do to get integrating
said to ask a neighbor for a favor
a small favor that's right like don't
will you build me a new house it's like
no that's not going to work but you know
um would you watch my here's my dogs on
the lawn would you watch them for two
minutes while I run down
corner stores like okay they can do that
well why would you do that well it opens
up the possibility of reciprocal
exchange it's very very smart because
now they can ask you for a favor so you
got that you get the trade thing going
and people who are highly social are
really good at me identifying and
maintaining reciprocal obligations so we
use each other as problem-solving
resources and a lot of our communication
is exactly that and so basically the
story you're telling isn't I was at
Point a and I went to point B and
everything work the story is this
instead it's half of this okay I was
that point a that's the top left hand
corner I was that point in I was going
to point B but something didn't work and
then things collapsed you know to a
greater or lesser extent depending on
the severity of the event you're you
know and and the closeness of your
friendship so you're telling the story
you're not going to tell catastrophic
stories to someone on a bus that you
just sat down beside unless you have a
mental illness and sometimes well really
it's the truth
sometimes you'll sit down on a bus and
someone who has a mental illness will
come and sit beside you and they will
immediately tell you horrible things
about their life and the reason for that
is they have to they don't have anyone
to talk to
they can't sort out their brains they're
so desperate they're so rude
they're in chaos they're so ruined that
they're that the the proclivity to
proclaim the chaos absolutely overwhelms
them and Europe you know you just can't
deal with something like that most of
the time because the magnitude of the
problem they're facing you with is way
beyond your capacity to solve so it's
just awkward that's not good anyways you
say I was going from point A to point B
didn't work now I don't know where I am
I don't know where it going and I'm lost
and you say well I know I experienced
when I was in a situation like this I
did this and I know someone else who in
that you know situation did this and
maybe you could try those or maybe you
just shut up and you let the person talk
and that's often extremely useful and
the reason you do that is because
they're thinking because people think
they think but they don't they talk
thinking is hard right it's a very
complex abstract cognitive operation and
I don't think that there are many more
people who can think then there are
people who can really read and that's
probably to two to five percent of the
population at most and so most of the
way that people deal with that is that
they talk and that's their thinking and
so they have some ideas about what might
be going on but they're mixed and muddy
so they're basically throwing out these
ideas you know did this happen
is he like this is she like that is like
did I do this it's like and then they
watch you and you know if you if you're
nodding about one they think oh well you
know that seems plausible and they lay
out another and you go you don't even
notice and they think no that's off the
table I didn't think that was a very
good idea but now I've got some social
what do you call it validation and soon
they talk it out and instead of having
sixty vaguely defined problems now they
have like five fairly tightly defined
problems they're feeling a lot better
about that right because it's five
snakes instead of sixty and maybe they
can deal with five snakes so you've
already helped them a whole bunch just
by listening you know and then maybe you
can be an active listener they lay out
their story and you say well you said
something here that doesn't make any
sense with this thing that you said so
you know how would you reconcile those
and you know it's this dialectical
process and so the person collapses into
chaos and they come and tell you about
it and then you rescue them if you can
out of the chaos and then they pop back
up the other side clinical practice that
is actually a formalized version of an
ideal relationship so the ideal you
think what's an ideal relationship well
I would say the ideal relationship is
where both of you are trying to get
better than you are and you're helping
each other do it it's something like
that and the lines because you know if I
have a good relationship with you I
would rather that you're the best you
you can be and advice I would assume me
that you would also like that for me I
mean things interfere with that because
you might say well if you know given how
horrible I am if that if my partner all
of a sudden got a clue they'd leave so I
better interfere with that as much as I
possibly can and people do that all the
time you know one of the things they'll
do is make sure their partner isn't too
attractive just like but you're so
attractive why are you with someone like
me it's like all kritis
see when you look attractive and that'll
fix that so people do that sort of thing
all the time this is the revolutionary
story this is the real story people tell
I was here I got bloody well knocked off
my perch and then for a while things
were not good and then you know I
reconfigured myself I learned some
things I did some exploration I made
some changes and poo off the other side
I come and I'm a better person for it
and if you listen to the way people talk
about their pasts especially with
regards to traumatic events they'll
often tell you that they'll say well you
know in retrospect that was the best
thing that ever happened to me
it's like those are the people who come
out the other side I'll tell you because
lots of people they fall into the belly
of the beast and they never come out you
see that in fairy tales sometimes say so
there'll be a hero and he'll conquer
some sort of dragon or some sort of
monster and when he cuts it open a bunch
of people who come out it's like yeah
they're the ones who got swallowed by
the thing and it is until that person
came comes along it solves the problem
that all those other people get to come
out so that's a revolutionary story it's
the archetypal revolutionary story and
it's the story of human progress so
socially politically economically
psychologically and you see that
reflected for example one of the things
I could tell you about Christianity is
that it's a revolutionary narrative at
the beginning so if you look at the
Bible structured as a piece of
literature at the beginning there's a
fall
everyone was doing fine then they wake
up and they find out that the bottom is
dropped out and then the whole rest of
this book is about okay how do you get
back there and actually it is in this
I'll tell you partly what the Bible is
is the attempt by broadly speaking
Western civilization so that would be
all the way from the Middle East West
it's the West's attempt to figure out
what's wrong with life and how to fix it
and it's it's it's the collaboration of
thousands of people over thousands of
years of course you can say that about
any ancient moral tradition so and the
question is well is there an answer to
the question well that's
that's one of the next things we're
going to try to figure out
well let's say okay you're driving down
the 401 your car breaks down you're off
by the side of the road it's like that's
not maybe it's snowing it's like how bad
is that well you don't know like maybe
someone slides on the snow and runs over
you you're dead it's really bad
so you're freaking out maybe your phone
isn't working so you check your phone
that's not working it's like all the
sudden things have got worse so this
person drives up behind you and they
stop your bit nervous about them because
what are they up to and they come up
they open that they open the hood and
they say well this thing's loose and
they put it in there it's like are you
happy well yes because what's happened
to you is magic so first of all you're
not in a car soon as it stops working by
the way it's only a car when it's
working when it's not working it's a
it's a bag of snakes
right it's like oh this car isn't
working what could be wrong wrong with
it Oh an infinite number of things none
of which I understand and then those
things are all attached to people who
are going to fix the car and like can I
trust them do I even know who they are
are they going to empty my wallet do I
need to have a new car you know um so
you don't know and then well your days
gone and then you know so all of a
sudden what happens is your your
environment complexified radically and
you get all nervous because there's a
lot of paths in there that you might
have to traverse to get back to where
you're going someone comes along and
goes tap it's like you're happy it's all
the complexity is collapsed into one
path that poop your poop your story is
now implementable again and you'll pay
people for that you do it all the time
it's like you've got a problem you take
it to an expert and they say well it
takes you an infinite amount of time to
traverse all these possible paths so
you're basically screwed but if you give
me $100 I can tell you how to do it in
five minutes I think yes that's worth it
so so you know of course it's efficient
that's why we train it's exactly why we
train it's like things are going to go
wrong with you that I could help and
vice versa
what a deal that's partly why we're
social and why we maintain it like as a
collective we're way more intelligent
than we would be but you know as one
person so all right that's a
revolutionary story
that's a collapse into the underworld
and a rebirth and so as soon as you know
that it's so cool to know that because
now whenever you read a classic story of
any sort you can think oh that's a
voyage to the underworld I've been there
and you have everyone's being there the
underworld is where that's chaos it's
chaos it's where you go when your life
falls apart it has a structure and
what's even cooler about that is once
you know this there's actually guides
through it it's like okay your world
fell apart what do you do about it
well dying of stress is a bad idea you
don't have to do that
so I was talking to one of the students
during break and we're talking about
character and I said well the best thing
you can do is build your character
here's a test of character it's like a
family members dying okay
are you useful or useless that's the
first question and then a deeper
question is do you make it as good as it
can be which isn't going to be that good
by the way or do you turn it into hell
because you can and lots of people do so
one of the tests of character is okay
there's a crisis like really how are you
gonna respond are you going to be
helpful are you gonna be useless or even
worse are you gonna make it worse I
would say helpful and the thing that's
so cool about human beings is that we
can do that people are so tough it's
insane
as long as they put themselves in the
position my sister-in-law works as a
palliative care nurse it's like all she
does is work with people who are gonna
die at two weeks like she's a happy
person partly because she goes home and
thinks hey this isn't a palliative care
award well really man you know things
can be worse so and she knows that it
she's reminded of it every day it's like
that's a person who does not take things
for granted